Smithsonian Zoo just revealed a new
giant panda cub named Bay Bay you heard
about Bay Bay yeah he's joining his
parents chianti on and may Chi Cheng and
they have him I guess on the zoo's
official panda cam 24 hours a day and
people are tuning in you see this little
baby panda yeah I got to tell you I have
tuned in a couple times usually there's
nothing cuter in the world than a panda
cub I hate to say this but I've been
watching it turns out Bay Bay it's kind
of an [ __ ] there's no other way to
put it
you'll see what I mean just check out
some of these highlights these are
highlights from a smithsonian panda cam
okay I see the parents I don't see Bay
Bay there is not
I'm 32 now it's feeding time and oh no
oh my god right now he's painting
obscenities on the wall he's really he's
doing donuts on an ATV I know what's
baby doing all these pants in the guy
tryna good shark I hate that guy okay it
looks like Bay Bay has escaped the Panda
enclosure we don't know where he is no
one knows where baby is if you see him
anywhere
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography